Abby Lee Miller is preparing herself for
the possibility of prison it's been
three months since the dance mom star
pled guilty to bankruptcy fraud a crime
that could land her ten years behind
bars nothing's worth that much money on
Monday Miller got candid about her
mistakes on the weekly podcast allegedly
quote I'm not going to deny anything
they were my mistakes I am taking full
responsibility for them she also
admitted she's scared to death of going
to jail and call the situation quote
humiliating and embarrassing the 49 year
old was charged with 20 counts of
bankruptcy fraud in June stemming from
her bankruptcy filing in 2010 she pled
guilty to one and in 2014 she told ET
her dance business had been struggling I
myself was in trouble I mean the whole
economy was bad people were losing their
businesses children's dance tuition was
the first thing to go in December she
topped the ETA about overcoming
obstacles my parents taught me hey you
go back in there tomorrow and you put
your chin up in the air and you do this
that and the other thing and you ignore
those people